[Música]
caminando por las calles de nuestra
ciudad podemos ver mujeres con enormes
vueltos en sus espaldas desde la mañana
hasta la noche como lo hacen que les
impulsa a realizar esa tarea todos los
días son sus familias sus circunstancias
en otro lado podemos ver en página 7
realiza una publicación que dice
ontiveros la joven que regala
una escuela de robótica en el alto en
este mismo artículo ella les pregunta un
grupo de niños y les dice han soñado con
estar en la nasa segundos después ella
misma se responde y dice yo he estado en
la nasa
es posible tengo un amigo astronauta
en su página del athletic de tweets nos
presentan al inass santander perdón y
ella se presentó en dos concursos de la
nasa en donde obtuvo los primeros
puestos si se dan cuenta estas dos
chicas han estado haciendo sus objetivos
marcando sus objetivos su camino y han
seguramente logrado después de mucho
tiempo de mucho esfuerzo de muchos
tropiezos de muchos problemas que
seguramente han tenido han tomado
decisiones y al final han logrado sus
objetivos pero hoy en día como nosotros
podemos hacer esto
siempre tenemos nosotros toda la
fortaleza de poder hacer todas las cosas
que nos planteemos tomar decisiones
parece sencillo pero a veces no lo es
una de las primeras decisiones que la
mayor parte de nosotros hemos tenido que
tomar en algún momento es y qué voy a
hacer con el resto de mi vida qué
carrera voy a elegir cuando toco mi
turno de poder hacerme esa pregunta
sinceramente pensé que nunca iba a
llegar ese momento pensé que me iba a
quedar pequeñita como como los simpson
como lisa como bart sin
responsabilidades sin compromisos con
nada pero el tiempo pasa y uno tiene que
tomar decisiones
no sabía qué carrera iba a elegir entre
este enorme abanico de opciones pero si
sabía cuál no iba a elegir y esa era la
carrera de medicina nos llevaron a un
paseo a la morgue y entre cinco segundos
no pude estar allí por más tiempo y tuve
que salir corriendo
ahora ha pasado el tiempo y puedo decir
que una de las formas de poder tomar
este tipo de decisiones es analizarlos
a nosotros mismos quiénes somos qué nos
gusta hacer sobre todo con que nos
podemos comprometer por un buen tiempo
para que a pesar de todos los problemas
a pesar de todas las barreras que veamos
en el camino podamos continuar podamos
seguir y podamos llegar a nuestro
objetivo
finalmente creo que todos queremos un
futuro lleno de éxitos prosperidad y
sobre todo felicidad
pero como lo hacemos como llegamos hasta
ahí como encontramos eso que nos haga
felices que nos sintamos nosotros la
pasión por hacer todo aquello nos
conocemos lo suficiente para poder
hacerlo
podríamos responder a la pregunta que me
gustaría estar haciendo de aquí a cinco
o tal vez diez años
es muy complicado verdad
nos queremos lo suficiente sobre todo
para poder hacerlo hoy en día las
aplicaciones como facebook netflix
google y muchas otras parece que nos
conocen más a nosotros que nosotros
mismos como lo hacen pues con la
información que nosotros le damos con
cada clic con cada megusta con cada
búsqueda nosotros les estamos proveyendo
información y ellos nos están
devolviendo en algún tipo de servicios
pero nosotros somos generadores de datos
cada minuto cada segundo estamos
obteniendo datos de todo
y estamos generando esa información sin
embargo nosotros mismos no somos
conscientes de toda esa información que
estamos generando deberíamos nosotros
poder responder a la pregunta que les
hecho hace 5 segundos de forma rápida
porque porque no hay nadie que nos
conozca más que nosotros mismos estamos
con nosotros las 24 horas al día 7 días
a la semana y 365 días al año conocemos
nuestros secretos más íntimos incluso
aquellos que hemos contado a nadie
porque no podemos responder esa pregunta
con tanta facilidad como deberíamos
poder hacerlo
realmente es porque tal vez no nos
conocemos lo suficiente tal vez no nos
damos el tiempo de poder contestar a
esas preguntas a nosotros mismos porque
no nos enamoramos de nosotros mismos
démonos esta oportunidad cuando nos
gusta alguien tratamos de saber qué
música le gusta que le gusta comer para
poder de alguna forma acoplarnos a su
forma de vida porque no hacemos eso con
nosotros de manos el tiempo de poder
conocernos
salgamos de este pequeño espacio de
confort que tenemos este espacio
pequeñito pero que conocemos cada
pequeño rincón
seamos libres es como ese pequeño ese
trabajo que estamos viendo cada cinco
segundos si es la hora de salida y nos
damos cuenta que recién son las diez de
la mañana ese trabajo en donde no nos
sentimos creativos en donde pensamos que
no tenemos las salas suficientes para
poder salir y poder ser más creativos
salgamos de ese espacio de confort yo
estuve ahí también tenía un trabajo con
un sueldo muy bajito pero que me
permitía pagar las cosas que yo quería
pero además mis papás estaban súper
contentos con este trabajo porque porque
tenía seguro social tenía derecho a
poder enfermarme como dicen
y tenía estaba pagando mi futura
jubilación pero eso realmente no era lo
que me hacía feliz
entonces porque no buscamos un trabajo
al que no le llamemos trabajo un trabajo
al que le dediquemos nuestra pasión al
que le dediquemos 25 horas al día y
seamos felices con ello utilicemos
nuestras ilusiones utilicemos nuestros
miedos utilicemos incluso la avaricia de
poder querer más mejores cosas para
nosotros mismos en mi caso fue el miedo
pero no el miedo a poder enfrentar cosas
nuevas sino fue el miedo a tener que
ejecutar tareas repetitivas todos los
días y además que no tuvieran retos ese
mismo miedo fue el que me llevó al otro
lado del mundo a poder eliminar esas
lagunas mentales que a veces nos hacemos
nosotros mismos yo pensé que al ir al
otro al otro lado del mundo iba a
encontrarme con como gigantes
extraterrestres con años-luz de
tecnología de lo que yo conocía y yo me
veía a su lado súper pequeñita pero al
llegar ahí me di cuenta que ni era
pequeñita y tenía todas las capacidades
para poder realizar todos los objetivos
que me había trazado
a veces somos nosotros mismos quienes
nos ponemos piedras en el camino y estas
piedras las convertimos en montañas en
cordilleras que no nos permiten realizar
nuestros objetivos
trabajemos en ello seamos como jim
carrey en la película sí señor en donde
tan sólo eliminando el no de su
vocabulario logró que se le abrieran
muchas puertas
seamos también como
como marie curie quien a pesar de tener
muchos problemas en ese tiempo porque a
la mujer no se le permitía estudiar
logró sacar no sólo un premio nobel y
dos premios nobel uno en física y una en
química si ellos pudieran hacerlo
nosotros también
desde mi posición the ambassador man in
data science
pude ver que muchos jóvenes y no tan
jóvenes se acercaban a nuestros talleres
de inteligencia artificial y machine
learning para aprender y aprendieron y
luego comenzaron a tener más confianza y
después se presentaron a la data tone la
data tona es un evento que en la
universidad de stanford realiza cada año
proponiendo cada año nuevos retos y este
grupo de personas lo logro presentó sus
resultados logrando posicionarnos como
que existimos dentro del planeta algo
que fue un gran logro para nosotros
muchas veces nos arrepentimos más de las
cosas que no hacemos que de las que si
hacemos entonces hagámoslo hace muchos
años me ofrecieron un trabajo en santa
cruz al cual no accedí uno de los uno de
los motivos fue porque recién había
estado aquí como cuatro meses y quería
estar con mi familia pero hasta el día
de hoy me pregunto qué hubiera pasado si
es que hubiera aceptado ese trabajo
donde estaría que hubiera hecho
para poder llegar a un momento en donde
no nos arrepintamos de las cosas que
estamos haciendo una de las soluciones
que se proponen es analicemos nuestros
datos analicemos que tenemos en este
momento
veamos cuáles son nuestros conocimientos
y tomemos decisiones en función a ello
actuemos en función a ello no porque no
tenemos marc no podemos ir al otro lado
del mundo
vemos el coraje de aceptar los retos que
nosotros mismos nos vayamos a plantear
utilicemos por ejemplo el análisis de
datos de la inteligencia artificial
ustedes dirán análisis de datos
inteligencia artificial muchos de
nosotros cuando pensamos en inteligencia
artificial pensamos en películas como yo
robots o terminator o tal vez en
servidores malvados como la reina roja
de operación umbrella o tal vez en la
skynet no que trata de conquistar el
mundo
que entre paréntesis existe el sky mit
pero bueno
entonces y en un entorno un poco más
académico tal vez estamos pensando en la
máquina de turing que trataba de
descifrar los mensajes alemanes a
finales de la segunda guerra mundial
o tal vez estamos pensando en estas
ferias tecnológicas en donde vemos
robots no con ciertas habilidades
humanas pero y como lo hacen ustedes
piensan que es simplemente ensamblar una
serie de circuitos y ya está pues les
cuento que no para poder hacer que ese
robots pueda enfrentarse y pueda
realizar varios eventos lo que hacen es
analizar los datos de miles y miles y
miles de azafatas en el caso de un robot
que sea de atención al cliente en el
caso de robots que se puedan dedicar a
la música o al deporte también les
proveen análisis de datos de miles y
miles y miles para poder de alguna forma
emular el comportamiento de una de una
persona hagamos nosotros lo mismo
tenemos nosotros esa capacidad de poder
generar muchos datos
y podemos analizarlos a nosotros mismos
kabul y un experto en inteligencia
artificial que trabajó en google trabajó
en apple y ayudó a la china a levantar
toda la parte tecnológica de la
inteligencia artificial nos dice en uno
de sus últimos libros que muchas de las
carreras que hoy conocemos van a
desaparecer sobre todo aquellas que
carezcan de creatividad carreras como
ser conductor tal vez el camionero o
incluso ser hematólogo o radiológicas no
sé si está bien dicho
pero están destinadas a desaparecer en
aproximadamente 15 años nosotros podemos
decir no eso falta mucho pero el tiempo
pasa muy pronto estamos en la cuarta
revolución de la tecnología ha pasado
todo tan rápido que apenas podemos
darnos cuenta hay generaciones que ya
han crecido con la internet y toda la
parte de la tecnología
ahora que sabemos que todas es toda esta
información de que hay carreras que van
a desaparecer esa información adicional
que tenemos que poner en nuestras bases
de datos internas y hacer las partes de
nuestra toma de decisiones
pensemos en que tenemos que ponernos un
objetivo pero también pensemos en que
tenemos que ponernos retos pero no esos
objetivos de fin de año esos objetivos
en donde decimos si voy a leer tantos
libros voy a ir al gimnasio y tal
cuántos de nosotros hemos cumplido esos
objetivos hasta ahora estamos en agosto
luz
google nos propone una metodología que
es los softwares que se basa en
objetivos y resultados clave la clave no
está en que nos pongamos objetivos más
alcanzables no google nos dice según sus
estimaciones que la mayor parte de las
personas llega a cumplir el 70 por
ciento de los objetivos
no importa si estos objetivos son muy
altos o si son chiquitos entonces mejor
planteamos un alto verdad
entonces nosotros necesitamos
plantearnos estos objetivos buscar
resultados pero en tiempos más cortos no
planteamos un objetivo tan alto pero los
resultados vayamos los midiendo de a
poquito
tal vez tres meses tal vez dos tal vez
uno depende de cada uno de nosotros
démonos la oportunidad de triunfar pero
sobre todo démonos la oportunidad de
fracasar aprendamos de nuestros fracasos
analicemos los datos que tenemos
pongámonos un objetivo
busquemos resultados
querer es poder sólo es necesario querer
para hacerlo
[Aplausos]